re bonjour madame messieurs pour une
sixième journée consécutive les
bombardements se poursuivent sur la
bande de gaza de même que les tirs de
roquettes en direction d'israël le bilan
des victimes s'établit à au moins 95
morts du côté palestinien et à trois du
côté israélien des chiffres qui
pourraient changer rapidement notre
envoyé spécial jean françois bélanger
est à gaza et vous allez le voir il est
littéralement au coeur de l'action
pour les habitants de gaza le principal
défi de savoir où aller pour être en
sécurité certaines cibles potentielles
sont plus évidentes que d'autres comme
ce commissariat de police ici
entièrement détruit par une gigantesque
explosion l'année dernière qui a tout
souffle et c'est aux alentours jusqu'aux
étals de ses magasins en face le
principal danger cependant ces cas
plupart des cibles sont loin d'être
aussi évidente et quand on parle de
signes qui peuvent apparaître évidente
cet immeuble en est un très bon exemple
c'est un immeuble à bureaux qui abrite
plusieurs organes de presse entre autres
des chaînes comme la fin allemande zdf
on parle aussi des siennes en radio et y
aurait aussi différents médias arabes
qui étaient sur place il y avait des
compagnies une compagnie informatique
par exemple qui étaient là ici au niveau
du troisième étage et une c'est à ce
niveau là que le missile aurait frappé
évidemment les gens l'immeuble n'était
pas complètement désert il y aurait eu
des avertissements avant des gens
auraient pu évacuer l'immeuble était pas
entièrement désert au moment où la caf
s'est produite il y aurait donc déjà au
moins un mort il ya trois décès qui ont
été vaincus on attend de savoir si il y
en a d'autres qui
pour sortir les secours sont sur place
en tout cas il ya toujours un petit côté
aléatoire dans ses frappes là c'est un
peu ce qui embête la population locale
puisque on nous dit certaines personnes
nous disent du bout des lèvres que oui
effectivement il y avait un bureau de
ramasse y avait des militants du hamas y
avait pignon sur rue dans cet immeuble
cependant tout le monde n'est pas au
courant c'est un petit peu ce qui était
assidu dans toute cette histoire c'est
qu'en fait il n'y a pas vraiment de
cibles militaires à proprement parler
tout est un petit peu les lignes sont
toujours un petit peu mélangés entre les
civils et militaires lancent dans ce cas
ci ce qui fait que la population le cgv
jamais vraiment où aller pour être
vraiment en sécurité alors c'est sûr
qu'on a regardé ici ce qui se passe du
côté du caire pour des fous de l'acompte
pourparlers de paix
alors viens d'entendre un explosion très
forte et on voit ici la colonne de fumée
derrière on entend un avion ici et en
permanence au dessus de nous il ya des
drones de l'armée israélienne qui
patrouille qui sont ici on sait qu'ils
sont partout on entend par exemple
évidemment actuellement les sirènes des
voitures qui vient de déclencher les
secours vont se rendre sur place on ne
sait pas encore exactement qu'est ce qui
a été touchée mais c'est sûr que c'est
quelque chose qui est constant ici
c'était intelligent mais toujours un
petit peu dans la crainte face on va se
coucher parce que les ambulances qui
doit passer les secours sont en route et
se dirige sur place on va y aller aussi
par la suite un autre ambulance
il ya toujours un petit côté aléatoire à
ses frappes là puisqu'on ne sait jamais
vraiment où ça va arriver quand ça va
arriver israël dit donner des
avertissements cependant il faut voir
jusqu'à quel point c'est efficace une
chose est sûre la population essaie de
se mettre à l'abri jamais évident de
savoir où aller pour être vraiment à
l'abri à gaza jean françois bélanger
radio-canada gaza